Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in the fifth chapter, the chapter of
vigilance of Allah authored by
and the first narration, the narration
of Omar
Omar.
is what?
And what year did he die? Well, was
he martyed?
What year? Huh?
Oh, come on. You're so close.
Come on. 13. Yes. Very good. Very good.
Thank you.
Who was he killed by?
Anybody know?
Who martyed Omar?
Abu Abduli.
Very good. We have a historian here.
Mashallah.
This is our
should know everything about him. every
single breath that was recorded for
Omar, we should memorize it.
So
he tells us that after the prophet Sam
was asked by this man
and this third question tell me about
this is the purpose of this narration in
this chapter
and
is What in in the Arabic language it
means what
is to perfect something. Perfecting
something. You do it over and over and
over until you become a master at it.
You perfect it. This is called and this
can only come
after years of dedication and
discipline. And this also tells us
something about the teachings of Islam,
Islam, iman, etc. All the other things
we're going to learn here. What it tells
us is that Islam is a discipline.
It's not something that you're just
naturally you are or you're not. It's
not that a person is either a liar or
not. Always. No, it's not that a person
or not. No, it is something that a
person in it intensifies and it can also
decline.
And that is the situation with every
discipline. A person has to discipline
himself. Do it over and over and over
until he perfects it. Now, what is going
on in the heart and in the mind that
will drive a man to perfect Islam and
Eman? What is the thing that will drive
him to perfect it? It is how many
pillars does have
one. one pillar and that is
what drives a man to perfect. It is that
you worship Allah as if you can see him.
And if you cannot see him, then you know
and acknowledge always that he can see
you. Subhanahu wa ta'ala. I think every
single person here knows this narration.
Right? This narration
is to the narrations of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam what Bakar is to
the rest of the Quran.
Meaning it is the it is the essence of
all narrations. Meaning all other
narrations of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam are an explanation for this
narration.
Just all of the Quran is an
explanation for fat.
All of the Quran is is an explanation
for surah al
and Bak
and all of Bakarah
and surah are an explanation for al fat.
And so
after he asks him about
he asks him about the hour the day of
judgment.
So here he says
tell me about the hour. the hour meaning
the day of judgment when
the world will end when the horn will be
blown.
And the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
says
the one who's being asked has no more
knowledge with respect to its time
than the one who is asking. So here we
have the most knowledgeable angel asking
the most knowledgeable man and neither
of them have an an idea as to when the
hour will be and this is in accordance
with the statement of Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
that the knowledge of the hour meaning
when it will be it is reserved with
Allah.
It is with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. So
he says,
"So tell me then about its signs,
its indicators,
those things that will come to be before
the hour actually is starts. The prelude
to the hour. What are the signs of the
hour?
in the Arabic language is an indicator
or a sign.
In one of the wordings of this narration
meaning one
indicator in this wording
is
meaning its most prominent signs of the
day of judgment. What are the most
prominent signs? He says,
[Silence]
So he mentioned here two signs of the
day of judgment. I want these two signs
as we mentioned before
this narration. The scholars tell us all
other narrations
are an explanation of this narration.
Okay. Just all of the Quran is an
explanation for
fat, right?
All of the Quran is an explanation of
fat. That's why it comes first in the
Quran.
That is the essence. Now the rest of the
Quran is expounding upon those seven
verses.
The same thing with the narrations. All
other narrations are an explanation of
this. So any narration dealing with
Islam is an explanation of this part of
this narration. Any narration dealing
with seeking knowledge is an explanation
of this. Any narration dealing with eman
is an explanation of this. Any narration
dealing with the signs of the hour is an
explanation of this.
Now there are hundreds of narrations
speaking about the signs of the day of
resurrection.
But here he chooses two
two to mention.
The first one he says that a slave girl
will give birth to her master.
And in another wording that a slave girl
will give birth to her female master.
So here we have the first sign as he
says the first sign of the day of
judgment. A slave girl. Is this one
slave girl? No. This is a type of
person, right?
Meaning a type of person will will
manifest and that is that a slave girl
during those times near the day of
judgment will give birth to her master.
And the second sign that he mentions is
that you see the
barefoot,
hardly clothed, naked
shepherds of sheep
that are building buildings
and they are competing with one another
in the height of their buildings.
These are very two pe two very peculiar
signs of the day of judgment because
first of all how can a slave girl be a
slave when she is giving birth to her
master?
That's very bizarre.
The next one is
that you see you observe
the naked barefoot
shepherds,
right? Shepherds here is not a dig at
their profession. This is speaking about
their their competence and the kind
of people that they are. These are not
people that are highly educated.
These are not people that are highly
proficient
or people that are very
cosmopolitan
if you will. These are shepherds, right?
They have ve very little civility.
Yet these individuals, you will see a
type of person manifest near the end of
time where
this kind of person,
naked, barefoot
sheep farmer will be having so much
money,
so much wealth that they will start to
compete with one another in high-rise
buildings. One will build 50 stories.
The next one will build 60, 70, 80. Who
has the tallest building? I have the
tallest building. We have the tallest
building. Oh, now they have the tallest
building. Now we're going to build the
tallest building. Right. I heard that
they're thinking about building a
building that's taller than our
building. So, we're going to build one
that's even taller than their building.
and it's going to be magnificent and the
whole world is going to love us. This is
the kind of person that is going to
manifest near the end of time. So we
don't just have two types of people but
we have two two types of mentalities
two mentalities here. The first
mentality
is that a person is born
feeling as though they are the master of
their own mother, their own parent.
The second mentality
is people that are shepherds, naturally
simple people, uneducated,
barefoot and naked.
Even if they put clothing on, they'll
always be barefoot and naked.
Yet they will be what? Competing with
one another and high-rise skyscrapers.
And so we will expound upon these two
mentalities tomorrow inshallah
[Arabic recitation]
you said something very interesting. You
said
which is interesting because his Abu
but his daughter's name is
right but his house.
Interesting.